los ríos de lava se han convertido en
una imagen cotidiana en la palma desde
el 19 de septiembre el volcán de cumbre
vieja no ha cesado su actividad pero el
sábado con la ruptura de su cara norte
las coladas incrementaron llevándose por
delante varias casas de la localidad de
todo que vivimos pues en casa encerrado
pero el terrenito que tenían todos
los recuerdos de mis padres
pero diría que ya se sabrá todo esto ya
de una vez por todas que nos siguiera
haciendo daño porque es que cada vez
está haciendo más años pasando por zona
que se pensaba que no iba a pasar y está
pasando a pesar de los numerosos
movimientos sísmicos a raíz de la
actividad volcánica este sábado las
autoridades locales decidieron reabrir
el aeropuerto de la isla y aseguraron
que las coladas actuales no representan
un peligro en este momento con las
cantidades de lava y la posición y
movimiento de la colada no estamos en
necesidad de hacer todo eso puesto que
ya tenemos todo lo que está por debajo
evacuado entonces también pido en ese
aspecto tranquilidad y estar siempre
atento a las indicaciones que hagan las
autoridades de protección civil desde
que el volcán entró en erupción su lava
ha engullido al menos 480 hectáreas de
tierra en la palma
más de 1100 edificios junto a la
evacuación de cerca de 6.000 personas